the president is taking a victory lap of
sorts over the North Korean news and he
has a new dire warning for a wrong chief
White House correspondent John Roberts
has all of that for us tonight from the
North Lawn could even jump bracket
evening to you the release of the three
Americans detained in North Korea was a
goodwill gesture that really has turned
into a major confidence-building step
one that appears to have only enhanced
president Trump's optimism about what
comes next meeting with his cabinet
today President Trump praised the
release of the three American detainees
by North Korea saying it bodes well for
his upcoming summit with Kim jong-un I
think this is something that nobody
thought was going to happen for years or
more and I really believe it's gonna be
a great thing for North Korea great
thing for South Korea and Japan with the
time and place for a meeting set
president Trump said an announcement of
where and when will be made within three
days but he has given up on his idea of
having it at peace house in the DMZ will
it be the DMZ it will not be with the
DMZ off the table Singapore remains the
most likely location for the two leaders
to meet asked today if he deserves the
Nobel Prize for his work to bring Kim to
the table president Trump deferred
everyone thinks so but I would ever say
I finished the prize I want is victory
for the world the president remains
optimistic that the summit will happen
but cautions that it could be derailed
president Trump also said another
warning to Iran today if you restart
your nuclear program you do so at your
own peril that would advise Iran not to
start the nuclear program I would advise
that very strongly if they do there will
be very severe consequence
Iran's Ayatollah Khamenei today hinted
that Iran may indeed restart its program
and as the American flag was burned in
the Iranian parliament the Ayatollah
trolled President Trump on Twitter
saying US presence a low and ludicrous
behavior wasn't unexpected Iranian
nation is persistent while former US
presidents passed away this man's corpse
will also be were
food while IRI stand strong and new
developments in the Michael Cohen case
today the Treasury Department has
launched an investigation into how
financial records of Cohen shell company
essential consultants became public the
attorney for stormy Daniels Michael
avenatti posted a lengthy document
online detailing payments to essential
among them $200,000 from AT&T at a time
it was looking for government approval
of a proposed merger with Time Warner
$500,000 from Columbus Nova a firm with
ties to Russian oligarch Viktor
Vekselberg and 1.2 million dollars from
Novartis Pharmaceuticals
in a statement Novartis acknowledged a
year-long contract with Cohen at
$100,000 per month
AT&T said it contracted Cohen in early
2017 to provide insights into
understanding the new administration
Columbus Nova acknowledged payments to
Cohen but insisted reports today that
Viktor Vekselberg used Columbus Nova as
a conduit for payments to Michael Cohen
are false as to the where and when of
where and when President Trump might
meet with Kim jong-un the leader of
North Korea with the caveat that things
can change and that the whole thing
might fall apart altogether the planning
is being made right now by the White
House for Singapore in early June there
are a number of reasons why the DMZ
wouldn't work not the least of which are
the thousands of journalists who were
expected to attend the summit but just
isn't enough room Brett John Roberts
live in the North Lawn John thanks